listen Israel and Ghana national Jade
Alania what you did see odd sensation
polish supporter war machine she it's so
poorly person P so so cool
polka still man I should take the end
what was the effects being placed on
that list what's been the effects on
your company on your business don't make
a fool shop but uncle the chicken - I'm
sure she don't know ah slits which add
essential needs machine on the one
domain watch my suggest Bonita the world
Singhania shall indeed to show you this
over D Y P nautical catchy de Sola zum
asajj indeed when she came in she you
co-leading phony enter your daughter was
arrested in Canada because of an
extradition request by the US can you
take us through your reaction when you
heard that news Taiji challenge which
you're her cafe so Hawk or no qin qiong
AKA here 20 new minute sheila learn the
out here the watch on jung-hwa got home
there are persons Hydra [ __ ] honey girl
and the BB me like horses yeah goody
come on target 20 so you get her jump my
ass you got thoughts of what just forget
a hooker Fiala to do you know titled on
your job why you can't hide she's using
I want to talk about some of those us
concerns the relationship between far
away the perceived relationship between
highway and the Chinese state the first
thing I know you've talked about it
before but the National Intelligence law
in 2017 this law states that any
organization and citizen shall support
and cooperate in National Intelligence
work with the Chinese state I mean it
unequivocally scum pennines public or
private must work with and be directed
by intelligence agencies that has been
caveated but why should we not just take
the law as it stands in black and white
but color you want me look like a you
want the body trattoria [ __ ] be seeking
you you if I was so on quite other
cities recent one might want this same
beta Y which how would your poor time
out of my hands and data to play them
quite a peak relationship to outsiders
with private businesses how did you
describe how his relationship with the
Chinese Communist Party DJ would be she
sent some chocolate you got funny
they're quite sure Jericho yo get your
what's up for Joe shoot the way shoots
try a meal question since this crisis
began the conflict between us and Huawei
what conversations have you had with the
Chinese leader show you what were their
push out to your heart do you wanna
would you somehow de la Morita tell um
who does she want - well I indeed she
bath planet now why we need to go since
I'm doing not to but super patiently
okay need you can make what they want
why we're just changing what being what
you're sending me there just to get it
straight to sum up the US government is
actually being helpful to who are away
while the Chinese government is being
unhelpful to Huawei boy
yeah real terrible it's a machine why
changes I mean puts my dear woman
pertain for like which I might only for
my one day you will want mission a good
manner when she some my book or I put in
Gunsan the whole you're a member of the
Communist Party here in China
sure and I'm box taking an oath correct
so some of that it says you promised to
be lured to the party work
enthusiastically fight for communism all
my life be ready at all times to
sacrifice everything for the party and
the people and never betrayed the party
do you still abide by that oath nah you
ain't gonna share just yo which led for
a bunch of ways to Miami hua chenyu for
chanson addition to so much before